as minnesota timberwolves currently
ranked seventh um in the western
conference at 37 and 29 fresh off of a
beatdown of the trailblazers last night
joining us here on the rich eisen show
right now is uh the the head coach
of the uh
of the minnesota tim wolves chris finch
how are you chris
i'm great rich how about yourself i'm
doing fine
are you uh are you a seahawk fan or
anything just gonna take that stab i
know you spent a lot of time over in the
uk and uh over uh in europe uh you know
getting your coaching career settled but
i just decided to take that stab to
start off this interview i'm actually a
die hard eagles fan grew up outside
philadelphia but okay how how difficult
is the afc west right now
did you think you'd come on this show to
break down the afc west for just even a
split moment but uh at any rate
well it might be my favorite sport so
i'm not i'm happy to talk about it okay
but you're from you're from the philly
area huh is that where you're from oh
yeah i grew up right i grew up in
reading pennsylvania which is about 40
miles outside okay so did you spend a
lot of time in the spectrum back in the
day for you i did spend a lot of time
actually um
used to go down i worked with kevin
mchale for five years in houston as an
assistant and i told i always told mack
i was like i used to boo the heck out of
you on sunday afternoons down at the
spectrum yeah you and about 16 000 other
people
those are the days right dr j the zinc
on the microphone right the zinc yeah
absolutely yep dr zinkov oh that's right
i remember that back i thought my
brother went to to uh the wharton school
of business in penn he took me to a game
of the spectrum back in the day it was
one of my favorite um
nba moments you know and now obviously
you have got a heck of a young team
right now um what is your challenge to
keep these kids um playing the way that
they are maybe get yourself out of a
plan situation and uh move forward this
year yeah the biggest challenge is like
continue to grow and improve
through successful moments you know
young teams like
you know it's great to have success but
it's all relative right like we're not
we're anywhere near the finished product
we know we're part of a process so
keeping them focused and
um you know just really taking it step
by step and understanding you know
you're gonna still have some
inconsistency with young roster
but we've we've been really fortunate to
have
carl anthony towns leading us as an
all-nba caliber season
and his consistency has allowed us to
kind of you know settle into a groove
here
well what'd you think of his three-point
victory i i uh at the all-star game
because i really liked what he had to
say afterwards
about trying to break the mold and try
to show folks um that don't judge a book
i guess by its height right and and
i kind of dig that and i'm wondering
what what you see on a daily basis that
might actually
uh echo those sentiments coach yeah i
mean he's often referred to as one you
know the best shooting big man in the
game i think he's one of the best
shooters in the game period
um you know watching it every day it's
effortless
he has incredible range because of his
size and strength he's able to get it up
over
anybody i mean it's not many contested
shots that he even takes we've been
encouraging him to take more
uh just because he shoots at such a
great clip and it sets up everything
else he does
it's really i think the game is in an
incredible place right now you have
these
skilled big guys leading the charge
whether it's inbeat or jokage
giannis you know you can throw in there
too like
it you know we've moved way past the
days where big guys are just back to the
basket and
plodding around the floor like these
guys are you know microcosms of an
offense all to themselves
chris finch minnesota timberwolves head
coach right here on the rich eisen show
anthony edwards talent is out of this
world and it also seems on occasion from
the outside looking in that he lives on
his own planet as well figuratively
um you got a good story for me on that
second part
coach what do you got for me i mean you
pro i mean you know the things that you
guys
see him say and do are you know it's
basically that's life with anthony the
great part about him and he's
he's uh he's a real he's a real deal
he's he's a a very mature kid like even
though he comes off sometimes
um super cocky and calm
did you just lose him huh i think we you
want to pop back on right when he's
getting to one of our favorite players i
know that you there coach
yeah we're here yeah we lost you you
said uh
you go
no yeah start again without anthony
edwards if you got you said that
he is uh yeah i said he's the real deal
with his talent
um and his potential and and the things
that you guys have had a window in to
see that you know some of the crazy
things he may say the great thing about
anthony is like here's a maturity about
him that both most young kids don't have
and that confidence is not driven by
insecurity it's very self-aware like he
knows where he is and his development
curve he knows he wants to be a great
player he also you know he's highly
coachable
um
and uh and responds well to adversity so
these are all things that you want in a
young player certainly a young player
with star talent oh wait is there
something where you couldn't believe he
had he didn't know about or something
like
i guess my favorite one of those is when
uh my friend mark glory by the way who's
got a big heart and uh he helps run my
40-yard dash for st jude children's
research hospital um and the ownership
group the new ownership group uh took
over he had no idea who alex rodriguez
was he had no clue oh no no you know
yeah we had our last road trip of the
season
uh was
last year was down to we had a florida
swing so we gave him an a-rod jersey you
know
[Laughter]
fantastic and then he came over to me
once in a game and uh
uh
he said to me i i need to learn how to
take a charge i said uh yeah i guess
what does that mean incredible
yeah he didn't know he's never taken a
charge in his life like you just you
know they come to the league so raw
sometimes you forget that
and just some of the fundamentals and
the basics that you think we're all
taught when we grow up playing the game
is
i mean right now it's different i mean
you know if you're average like one and
done player think about the last time he
might have been really coached or taught
anything it's probably a number of years
ago so
did you you didn't have to teach him
what the semicircle was right like you
didn't have to go there right
no i mean yeah that you couldn't pull
that off in today's in today's practice
environment oh my god i mean just wow
that is incredible he's so he's so
talented though i mean you've got a real
talented group in front of you and i'm
wondering if you know do you ever catch
yourself just looking at that you know
again like not lost in the x's and o's
or anything like that where you just can
sit back and go i got myself
uh a possible you know a good team and a
winner here you got that yeah i'm for
sure i mean i look you know i looked
into a situation that had good young
talent
um and some established talent too with
with d'angelo and um and carl
and so now you know we don't have to be
reliant simply on first or second year
players and they can kind of develop in
their own time
um
and we you know it's been fun to watch
him grow
for sure and you know and take to the
winning and become the competing and
just trying to get a mindset to where we
go out every night and we expect to win
which is not always where this franchise
has been so
not every job you walk into has these
type of players but i was fortunate
enough to have have it and you know
they've been great in allowing me to
coach them and respond to the things
we're asking them to do what's the um um
what's the best team you've seen played
against most challenging team i guess so
far this year yeah i mean
you know phoenix is just like they're
just a finished product you know they
they have it all they have you know the
the depth the experience obviously chris
paul debbie booker the explosiveness
they got
you know i can hurt you inside um
that's probably the most consistently
high level team we've seen
uh we were
fortunate or unfortunate i guess just to
play philly on the hardened debut we got
that's right
oh by the way
nice little hello from your hometown huh
right exactly right so
they i mean to me they look they look
real they look like the real deal too
i mean having worked with james in
houston for a number of years like you
can tell when he's locked in engaged and
playing at a high level
um
and you just you know embiid is dominant
on both sides of the ball
it's been a long time since we played
milwaukee but i'm still a big believer
in them as well
so yeah i mean you obviously the west is
is quite a gauntlet but um you know what
what do you tell your guys about
the possibilities this year do you use
the word championship i mean how do you
how do you go about that with them uh we
don't we talk openly about the playoffs
you know we want we want to be in the
playoffs that's our goal that's been our
stated goal from
the beginning of the season and we
haven't shied away from that i think
it's important to have something to
really push for helps you frame
and break down the season into kind of
digestible goals you know if you talk
about 82 game season how do you even
approach that when you're trying to map
it out for your players it's just too
big
but you can break it down into small
parts you relate those parts to a goal
our goal happens to be the playoffs you
know
and we can get there by finishing the
top six or we can get there by the
play-in route you know we don't really
care but
either way um you know our season's been
mostly successful and we want to finish
it off
in style so to speak and that's step one
for us i don't you know when you get to
the playoffs it's really about matchups
you can get a few rounds here and there
um
but you know we know we're team on the
grow on the grow and that's going to
take a couple years to be
you know considered a championship level
team coach appreciate the time greatly
um look for my call as you uh advance uh
towards the playoffs and
um you know hopefully for you make it
let's uh let's do that again thanks for
the call appreciate you having me on
thanksgiving you got it that's uh the
head coach of the minnesota timberwolves
right here on the richard show chris
french right here on the program
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here